So on the left hand side you'll see our
brand new office for all of our agents
to work in. I'm now going to come to
start up another instance of claude code
which is going to spin up our new agent
in this foyer area. Now we're able to
give the task exactly like we would
normally. For example, we can simply say
research the top five AI automation use
cases for e-commerce businesses right
now. Then create a one-page client pitch
doc summarizing the opportunity and
recommended tools. We'll send this off.
And now that agent is going to go up to
the research seat and go into sit there
to complete the task. Now we're able to
come down to the left hand side, create
a new instance which is going to start
up our idle purple agent now. And in
this use case we're going to go through
and say pull together a cold outreach
email sequence for ecommerce store
owners. Three emails, different angles
and ready to use. Now our agent's going
to walk off. He's going to go and sit in
the top leftand corner for that writing
task. As you can see, they're now
starting to work away in the background.
We're also going to come down to a new
agent, which will start it up again in
our foyer area. And this use case, we're
now going to come through and pull in a
CSV file. As you saw in the background,
that agent just walked back to the foyer
because it's now done and we need to
review it. Now, we're going to say,
"Please provide me with the key
insights." As you can see, he will go
down and sit in that analytics chair on
the left hand side completing that
specific task. What we can do is we can
see this purple agent here. You just
heard the tick in the background for
completing the task. As we can see here,
it's now asking for some information.
So, we could say we are looking for
option option A and we'll send it off
again. It's going to go back off try and
complete that task. So at any point in
time, we know exactly what our agents
are doing, where it needs our input, and
how we can improve it. And yes, this may
look like it has no functionality
whatsoever. And you're absolutely right.
It's just great to visualize it. But the
key part that I wanted to highlight with
this is this is definitely the way that
we're going to be able to start
visualizing how all of our agents are
working, how they're talking to each
other, and of course, what's going on in
the background for our agents, and where
we need to have the input provided from
us as users. As you can see here, our
agent's got a little speech bubble. So,
we're just going to say yes. So, it can
carry on working on that specific task.
The other one's finished, and that's why
it's come back. So, now we can always
see in a quick glance what our agents
are doing, how they're getting on with
the tasks, and if they've completed
their outputs. So, there we go. And both
of our agents have just finished up. So,
as we can see on the right hand side
here, we've got some insights from that
CSV file that I provided. It went off,
of course, to the analytics. then up to
the writing as well as every other step
that it needed. We can come back. We've
now got those email sequences ready to
go for us to review and improve and
change. And of course, we've got our
agents from before as well. So now
rather than having lots of boring of
course terminal looking interfaces for
us to work with, we can actually start
to visualize what our agents are doing,
what they're working on. And I think
this is the first step. Of course, as we
start to get more agentic workflows,
like we've seen from open claw running
in the background, we actually know in
this way what our agents are up to at
any point in time with a quick look.
We're able to use it within VS Code
natively. On the left hand side here,
you just need to come across to this
icon here, which is the marketplace and
extensions, and then you just need to
search for Pixel Agents at the top. As
you can see here, it's already got
13,000 downloads and being used, but as
we can see here, they've got the
original version, the original
characters, and it explains exactly like
what they would have in GitHub for us to
be able to use. So, for VS Code, I'm
just going to install it quickly. We're
going to say trust and install. Now, to
see it working now that we've installed
it, all we need to do is command shift
and P and then we'll do pixel agents.
And then as you can see at the top here,
we've got a few different options. We
just want to do show panel. And now at
the bottom here, we'll be able to see
the pixel agents as a new tab. Of
course, if we're going to be using this
with clawed code, we could close this
down on the left hand side for our
different marketplaces. And then on the
right hand side here, just make sure
they're in a terminal. We can start up a
clawed instance, say yes that we trust
it, and it will go through with the
basic layout. You can then come through,
add lots of different walls, furniture,
and everything else that you want, desk,
chairs, all of this stuff into your
different accounts. Now, if you're using
cursor as your main IDE, it's not going
to be as simple to get set up. Instead,
we're going to need to go across to
GitHub. Now, the way that it works is
essentially there's something called a
visx file that actually sits behind how
we can do basically the external
applications for us to see all these
different agents. We can come down and
copy this command here. And then you
want to simply come across to the
project where you've got all of your
data stored. So for example, VS code or
cursor. And then you just want to open
up a new tab. So in this case, we'll do
new terminal. We'll do claude in here.
And then all you need to do is say
please install this repo. And then you
paste the command in there. And you'll
be up and running. Then once you've got
it installed and you explained that you
want it to be up and running in cursor
you just need to do command shiftp up
the top you'll look for pixel and then
agents and again you'll just do show
panel then you'll be able to move it
around to wherever you want such as on
the left hand side here to see exactly
the agents. Now, this was built on top
of the framework which is the pixel
agents plug-in of course for VS Code and
the GitHub repository that's been
developed by the team Pablo and John. As
you can see in the background, this is
the default version that we're able to
get access to, but of course, we can
customize the entire way it looks. They
have a bunch of assets that of course
you can buy from them to set up the
different offices if you want to use for
their different settings, the different
office types, the desks and everything
like this that you can use. The same can
be said for all of their characters as
well which are simple stitch characters
for us to be able to use. As you can see
here, they got lots of examples that you
can use. The critical part is this
template here. The reason that that is
so important is because that's the
format that we need to make it actually
have the visualizations within our VS
code or cursor instance. But what we can
also do is copy this, come across to
platforms like key where we can generate
images. In this use case, I've used Nano
Banana 2. Simply put a prompt in here,
attach that character as a reference
image, and as we can see on the right
hand side here, it's gone through and
generated a complete set of agents for
us to use. So if you wanted to generate
your very own versions, it's nice and
simple to go through and do it. The same
can be said for the offices as well. If
you want to create your own offices,
I'll include a lot of resources in the
community for you to come and access.
But all we need to do is make sure that
we've got a reference image of an office
and then we give it a prompt and it
generates the output for the agents to
know where they need to sit. That's why
we have in the bottom leftand corner the
layout. As you can see here, we can then
come down and place furniture. We've got
the desks which we can select and paste
in here. Or for the way I've set mine
up, we just come across to chairs. We
get this little icon here, which of
course we can dot anywhere when it goes
green. And then we just basically need
to explain to Claude Code that is the
chair for editing, that is the chair for
analytics, publishing, whatever your use
case is. Then the minute the agent gets
given a task, it knows it needs to go
sit down at a specific desk. I'll have
the full prompt that I use basically to
go through and explain how we get this
output in the community if you want to
get access to it. But honestly, I
recommend just doing some reverse prompt
engineering, getting all of this into
your instance, and then just explaining
the outcome that you want and asking it,
how do I achieve this? And as I
mentioned at the start, you absolutely
don't need to have this. This is just a
fun way to gify a lot of what's going on
with your claw code agents and see how
they're operating. But it does touch on
our important point around of course
that iceberg effect that we have at the
moment. All we can see at the moment is
basically that we've got an active
agent. But we don't really understand of
course which files it's accessing, the
cost that sits between it of course if
we're using the API, any API is calling
decisions being made all in a
centralized place. if you've got lots of
these different terminals and agents
running off in the background. And I
absolutely think that this was a
definitely great step forwards and it's
an absolutely a great plug-in for that
visibility spectrum. Of course, you
don't need to use the one that Pablo and
the team have developed. You can
generate your very own version just
using basically Nex.js creating your own
dashboard or anything like that to run
it locally by just reverse prompt
engineering with claw code. But we are
starting to see more and more of that
shift as we become more agent managers
versus of course doers for everyday
tasks where we're actually able to go
from just pure terminal usaging actually
writing the commands ourself to now
having a bit of a better interface with
of course crawled code Germany and all
the other ones that we're able to access
and then we're starting to put this into
a wrapper interface with of course the
pixel agents that we did start to run
through but I think that we're still far
off that 100% vision of being able to
see every decision path mapped, being
able to see the deviations where they're
being flanked. And I almost see it as
being like that orchestrated vision that
we're able to see from process mining
tools like Salonius, how the different
processes are connecting to each other,
how different agents are working
together, whether that be a pixel agent
interface or something else. So, we're
definitely moving our way up the
spectrum of that visibility of what's
going on and having that nice gamified
way of seeing what it's doing. That's
all for this video. Make sure to come
across to the community, which is the
first link in the description, to learn
more about AI and automation. And have a
great day.